hey guys we are back again I probably
don't need to keep saying that you're
probably still watching but I'm Jess I'm
gonna keep introducing myself just and
I'm still Scott you're still sweet on
those each and every time yes do you
want to say do you wanna join us
you're still Ralph yeah we're all still
who we were at other points but Ralph is
new this is a Killa intro good lord
we're here to talk about what's the
horizon 3 which is pretty exciting
Europe cause cause cause everywhere
gorgeous looking cause none of the cars
because in Australia is yes I'm very
excited about the Australia pot I'm
gonna get to that but I I always go
crazy for these trailers because good
boy it is a beautiful looking game isn't
it well that's part partly jus are
largely jus I guess to the to the same
thing right yeah what attracted us to
Australia yeah incredibly beautiful
country big country incredibly diverse
let's let's play the big one so our
world is like twice as big as as the
last game horizon - yeah Reza did wasn't
small by any stretch but we didn't make
it bigger just to make it bigger we made
it bigger to fit and all the diversity
of that country has a man has it paid
off seems like there's a much bigger
focus on off-roading which it definitely
fits with the setting and like driving
through the outback with riding through
the jungle and and you've added a lot of
vehicle new vehicle types right to
accommodate this new style of racing
absolutely yeah and if you if you go to
the show Florida and we have that
there's a couple of them on show today
but yeah you're right I mean a lot of
rugged terrain right there Outback yeah
any asphalt roads you know put it great
for off-roading and we've introduced
racing buggies you can play one of them
on the show I've got trophy trucks and
like really extreme bake capable
off-road Oh Swisher was just eat up that
terrain that's fantastic and I have been
asked to bring up obviously you're
working with Australia but I have heard
you're working with kind of a
Frankenstein map of Australia where
things are in different places they are
in the world right yeah so I've heard
this feedback it's been it's been
wonderful
over the last couple of days we can
actually research that so this is news
to us right and I guess it goes to how
we make horizon games right so this
isn't the first right with the first
game was in Colorado the second game was
in France and Italy and this one's in
Australia and we've taken exactly the
same approach in all three yeah which is
to say we go there and we research
extensively right so if you look at the
architecture the foliage the wildlife
yeah you will you will recognize that
it's very authentically Australian but
then what we have to do is piece that
together into an open world and make it
a game which work you're right yeah yeah
absolutely
you know to be we're not the terrace
boards okay you know what we need to
make games we need to make games that
our players can get into and that work
for progression and fun and great
driving experiences so if things aren't
exactly in the place they are in real
life I'm happy to hear about them all we
know you know I feel like people
probably aren't coming to Forza horizon
to see exactly where all the states in
Australia are laid out so you probably
okay I feel that way yeah yeah but I
mean what Australia does do for us and I
guess the reason we've crammed so much
into this there's this world is that
Australia has so much to offer and if
it's not about cramming it and in places
where maybe it's not absolutely
geographically accurate or leaving them
out I know which option I'm always gonna
go far right I have spoken to my friends
about the fact that I was doing this
interview today and they just needed me
to pass on to you thank you so much for
including and remembering that Australia
is a place because we are in no games
right well I mean I think that's great
yeah it's not necessarily why we did it
but I love the fact it's off the beaten
track I love the fact that it's not like
you know a world that everyone is
familiar with from video games right you
know we looked at California but I feel
like I spent half my life in caliber
whereas you know horizon games are kind
of like like a dream vacation yeah and I
think I think Australia is a great place
to go on one yeah can we talk about how
the horizon games like have their own
kind of niche apart from the more
standard for subtitles yeah yes so I
mean we've been doing this for four
three versions now which is great so I
think we have a really strong
self-identity and I think people are
getting that they understand what
they'll get from a horizon it's
different from a motorsport game I think
they are very complementary you know a
lot of our players play both and and get
great things from both but certainly we
think of ourselves as all about fun
right it's about laid-back fun with your
friends it's not serious we don't take
ourselves too seriously you can see that
from the show floor demo right you know
you're racing against that Jeep
suspended from a helicopter
it doesn't make enormous amount of sense
but it is crazy fun and that's why we do
it the motorsport side is great as well
it's a bit it is a boat serious
competition it is about mastering cars
and tracks and racing lanes and apexes
and you can still get that from the
horizon games but it's much more
easygoing I think and I love that about
a bit that's part of the franchise I
think you touched on something very
important which is that horizon 3 is a
particularly social game that you now
have I believe four player co-op
throughout the entire experience which
is a series first from what I remember
it absolutely is just well remembered
yeah yeah we're excited about it we
showed it on stage and the Xbox briefing
on Monday it's as I said to you the
other day something that we've wanted to
do in horizon since the first game
because it feels like it's it's the
perfect fit you want to just explore the
world with your friends and go to a
festival with your friends right we
haven't done it before because we didn't
feel we could do it right and that's
really important because we've done it
right this time and by doing it right I
mean offering everything that's in the
solo game and making sure that you can
play it with your friends right it's not
a ring-fence subset of the game like you
sometimes see and that's fine for
certain games but for us we want to make
sure that you can drop in you can drop
out and the game just handles it you
kind of got a lot of like very different
vehicles this time around I know you
have an insanely huge roster of cars so
many this is the most right it's 150
right there you go I can't don't need to
be
you do this I'm sorry 100% right it's
more than 350 which is how many more
than horizon 250 more yeah you're right
this man yes there's great retention
there
yes 150 more than rising to really
stretch the the Carlos let you see it's
the biggest in the series to 8 and
that's allowed us to do a ton of things
right I mean new hot cars like the
Lamborghini chanting REO which is cool
it's on our cover it's really important
to us but it's not just about like
incredibly hot supercars although
there's a ton of them in the game
yeah it's about the off-roaders we were
talking about earlier it's also about
Australian domestic cars as well as a
remarkable domestic car culture and
showings are always asking me where are
we gonna see more Holden's wearing suits
in the game 74 Sandman the oldest Holden
years in the game this year both Ford
and Holden will make their final ever
production Utes in Australia and we've
got both of them in the game as well so
there's great Australian flavor to our
car list not just not just our world
I appreciate you just constantly
appealing to my I feel like I'm trying
to appease you I mean it's working so
great good I'd love to know like what's
your favorite thing that you might be
doing with supports on horizon 3 whether
it's something new or something that you
feel like the series is always nailed
like what is it that makes horizon 3 so
successful in its nation among all the
other racing games well driving game so
one thing that we are really excited
about it's something we thought about
right at the start of the game and it's
a sort of almost a philosophy that has
informed everything we've done in the
game which is we want to put the player
in charge like we're great as developers
at prescribing you know what you're
gonna do in the game hey right here's
the content work through it and and
we've done that in this game if you just
want to play the stuff that we've made
you totally can and of you know you can
spend a hundred hours easy getting
through it but what we've done is put
you in charge and we've given you a
feature called horizon blueprint which
will allow you to do it which means you
can create your own gameplay and you can
share it with your friends which is
awesome because for some players are
incredibly creative we know that because
the
cars and the cars and they take amazing
photographs and know they can create
their own gameplay whether that's events
or championships or even your bucket
less challenges which we demonstrated
the other day so I think that's the
thing I'm most excited about because it
turns a hundred hour game into a
virtually endless game and it doesn't
like virtually endless yeah I was like
to point out you also added stunt jumps
which I'm pretty excited about
who doesn't like big job yeah nobody
nobody doesn't like nobody doesn't yeah
yeah and so we saw in horizon 2 where it
wasn't a thing that we put in the game
but people just found massive ramps and
jumps and they're always getting them
and sticking them on lane and it was
hilarious and I hope they do that again
but we thought okay let's learn from
these guys and build these into the
world and make them competitive so it's
it's really got a lot of social elements
horizon 3 does not I would say it's the
most social racing game ever since us
yeah yeah it's interesting that you say
that because that chat is agreeing
really have said that they feel like
this is what perhaps other multiplayer
games have been like I said at the top I
think I think horizon in its essence is
about having fun with your friends yeah
and the thing that I think is most
exciting and maybe important about this
game is the fact that no you can have
fun with your friends across platform
right complete xbox one you can also
play in Windows 10 and those communities
complete together yeah so almost the the
technology the platform almost fades
away it's not important anymore it's
just about the game and your friends and
having fun in it together but another
guys alright I mean speaking of
technology though this so this is
actually launching on Windows 10 as well
those there and there's like cross cross
play I think even there's not just cross
saves but like cross play between
platforms absolutely yeah yeah so day in
date September 27th that's coming to
Xbox one and Windows 10 and yeah you'll
be able to seamlessly cuz all our online
is seamlessly it's just a button press
away and you can seamlessly play with
players on on either platform right and
we don't differentiate because it's
about fun it's about cooperation and I
think it's great that there's already
huge Xbox one for us a community will
know welcome and the Windows 10 PC
resent to the family
has it been difficult at all designing
the game to bring it to PC there's been
a lot of considerations I'll say that
this was probably not the world in this
respect but we have been thinking about
making a game for for PC as well as Xbox
one right from the start that's kind of
a paradigm shift for us in Forks it's
the first time we've done it so we've
been thinking about it for a long time
and you have to start thinking about hey
okay mice and keyboards support you
exactly that work in fact change up how
just different configurations of PC
affect everything but because we were
thinking about it right from the start
we were able to plan and design and
create it that way so actually it kind
of just works
yeah you mentioned Muhsin keyboard maybe
that made me think are you going to
include or offer support for driving
peripheral steering wheels and all that
kind of stuff
absolutely yes I mean you saw on stage
and Monday one of the guys where he was
playing on 110 was using a wheel and
patio set up will absolutely support
those peripherals um we haven't
announced the list of support
peripherals just yeah that's coming
later in the summer once we've
absolutely locked it down but but yeah
if you're serious about racing and
driving games on PC and you own that
wheel you want to get one then you
rising three do you think that's a
better way to play like would you
recommend people who want to play on PC
get like a gamepad or a wheel or
something or do you think it works just
as well with mouse and keyboard
I think his I think it's horses for
courses it's what your how you want to
play the game I know there's a lot of
guys in Andy who was in the BCD with me
is one of them he you know he swears by
driving with the wheel personally I'm a
pad guy I you know it works for me and
obviously on Windows 10 you can use your
xbox pad there and it's great as well
and you can even use keyboard too Steve
you know so we're supporting a whole
range of ways to play it's up to you
what you think is best
I play with a guitar hero controller if
I was like sitting there with you know
people always try to do that
DDR pad you try it someone will try it
out guarantee there'll be a youtube
video somewhere at some point yeah
interesting so how many different
locations are we getting around
Australia so so we thinking
types which is maybe not a word people
use ordinarily but is kind of like it
every environment style so everybody
knows about that
Outback I mentioned that before and we
have a big Outback area you know with
with tones and there's an airstrip in
there as well so there's lots of fun
things for you to do while you're there
and then there's canyons and gorges
there's we have we researched the Yarra
Valley within your wine country so
ruling hills and and vineyards again for
us arising to fans and then we have rain
forests we have the Gold Coast and we
also have Surfers Paradise you know
which is a cool high-rise set you know
which we haven't really had in the
cities before we had the city of neason
into but very different in architecture
and style than Surfers Paradise there's
a very different feeling yeah one of the
craziest things that I remember you
talking about the other day was you guys
apparently just pointed I think was like
a 12 K camera at the sky for hours every
day and captured like actual Australian
sunsets and included all that in the
game proper is that absolutely so
there's kind of two parts to this kind
of great story that the first part is
the technology angle and it's never been
done before and we've got incredibly
smart guys back at playground who have
worked a way to do it but the other part
was probably even more difficult it was
being in Australia like being in the
outback for a lot of the time yeah with
this camera pointed up at the sky and
this is the camera we built people
towards you couldn't build this kind of
rig but we did and we took that out
there but you had to stay with it every
hour of the day and its ruling 24 hours
to capture the full sky going over you
know they're absolutely all the
intricacy and and and variety that you
get in an Australian sky and obviously
everything in the outback wants to kill
you right yeah so yes that was a that
was a particularly arduous part of it
but I'm so glad we did it because the
results you've seen them in the game
they speak for themselves Hasek I mean
it looks gorgeous like I'm pretty
excited about it I think I think what
you've done with making a driving game
that just emphasizes the joy of driving
cause is a really cool thing I know
Scott's excited about it thank you so
much for coming by and stunt jumps thank
you so much for coming by to talk to us
about it thank you you know I'll say on
behalf of all the Australians thank you
yes I am heading off but Lucy will be
back with you in just a moment to show
you some other cool stuff